jean renoir une vie en oeuvre claude
jean philippe aux éditions grasset est
ce que c'est un essai d'appropriation à
la première personne est ce que c'est un
bain d'humanité c'est vous qui écrivez
ses mots pour définir l'art de renoir en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
vous adorez la personne dont vous parlez
et que vous savez admirablement la
mettre en scène je dois avoir vu de mon
premier renoir 15 ans donc et j'ai écrit
mon livre derniers temps donc c'est tel
quel le premier la règle du jeu et j'ai
été bouleversé sans rien comprendre un
sens absolument rien comprendre de ce
qui se passait sur cet écran mais il se
passait quelque chose de prodigieux je
voudrais qu'on évoque la chienne qui t'a
fait une 1931 qui est un de ses chefs
d'oeuvre absolu racontez-nous à votre
façon
le dédoublement de l'intrigant entre le
vrai et le jouer alors reste il s'est
passé des coïncidences étranges entre ce
que raconte le film et la vie des
interprètes renoir voix jannier mahrez
qui lui est plus ou moins imposé par la
production et dit abraham berger cette
fille ira très bien seulement il est
complètement évident qu'elle n'a jamais
joui et c'est très important pour le
personnage qu'elle va jouer puisque son
le personnage du maquereau les georges
flamengt douala tenir par là le pierre
berger et jean renoir organise carrément
une rencontre à la campagne entre jeanny
marc heather flamand et le résultat
dépasse leurs espérances
il tombe bien la main molle l'autre et
renoir constate que ceux qui le
souhaitaient ses produits georges
flamengt tiens jeanny marc est le plus
célèbre de ces films c'est je crois la
grande illusion
pourquoi cette cette suprématie cette
éminence de ce film admirable c'est vrai
mais qui n'est pas plus admirable que
par exemple la règle du jeu où une
partie campagne parce que je crois que
c'est un signe de la maturité
ce n'est pas un film humaniste avec and
east
c'est un signe ou réellement on a le
sentiment de l'humain ce qui amène les
réactions les plus extravagantes celle
de goebbels dix ans ce film est l'ennemi
cinématographique numéro un est celle du
président roosevelt qui dit tous les
démocrates du monde devrait voir ce film